change my roast beef roast potatoes
Yorkshire puddings some carrots and
cabbage and then maybe a really nice
sort of sexy gravy can I just say in
advance that I'm quite an intelligent
woman but when it comes to the kitchen I
don't mind admitting I'm a complete
bimbo what's that some hollandaise a
sort of sauce hollandaise assault
resource another pass dripping that's
gonna make the perfect perfect Yorkshire
pudding so the key to this is to have a
time plan yes everything else after that
falls into sink there's a top view it's
always keep your cloth there like that
so you've always got it to hand up and
down not over the shoulder not left
lying around and then when you want to
touch something in the oven you can
always just hold it there and lip it out
first thing the most important thing
will get the beef in now season the fact
season yeah because what that does get
the water in the fan makes it a lot more
tasty start off on 250 degrees there we
go so the first time we start one of the
of them yeah your pudding mix one two
and then finger and thumb in and just
lift open one egg okay yeah yeah
well human I'll get some milk better
pepper so it's fast and that's gonna
help you guys and stop them from
sticking do that much in there you put
milk in there just a tablespoon just put
that in there we go to the safe came one
that's it good living more good whilst
the beef is roasting away they should go
zoom and I would do the easy stuff roast
potatoes I have had nights where I'm
thinking God it would be so great if I
could cook right now
Christmas dinner sometimes I'd like
Christmas at mine and then my mom's like
no why do we have it at yours because
then we've got to cook everything we
need there and we have to bring
everything with us I like to get the
tray on top of the gas ring before it
goes in the oven it just stops it from
sticking
what's your fingers there just for
that's an awesome sense now if you start
to see the potato's coloring a little
bit let's take the beef put your fingers
like this and just touch your jaw like
that inside your cheek yeah
that means it's rare when you hit on the
beat like that so that's still quite
rare if it's medium it's firm it's like
your chin medium well done
absolutely amazing
just a few more topics the secrets to
turn them around turn it upside down so
they cook them beneath a little bit of
onion because the onions we're doing put
some of these tomatoes in the bottom all
they're gonna do is actually make the
gravy a little bit of sweet you know I
grew up in a two-bedroom counselors they
shared a bedroom oh brother this kind of
food we didn't need no I didn't need
there's quite a few foods that I was
kind of quite frightened of I must admit
like what well I mean the word organic I
immediately feel that something
disgusting yeah a long time I was
younger and when people used to say that
they were kind of vegetarian yes what's
that because everything was chicken
chips and beans fish chips please yeah
you know and that was it it is better
that should be in the fridge okay how
big do you want knobs be pass that
through sister
all right so how I got time to quickly
just put a bit of makeup on and brush my
hair make it look like this was
completely effortless yeah
now women back in the kitchen I love my
friends but they are quite judgmental
okay when it comes to my cooking I've
never seen her in the kitchen actually
saucy and they're just they're just
dreading it I think my think okay my way
a bit worried
don't worry about getting everything
sort of piping hot the Beast rested
Yorkshire puddings are served the room
temperature yeah yeah know what we'll do
before take the potatoes out we'll stick
them in the oven yeah absolute definite
trying to the place nice and clean
control beef looks delicious
yeah see how it's good together Calais
it's just all almost coming out like a
sort of a chain reaction
this has to be you'll piss through this
time yeah crispy a nice and life
actually the house yep myself good ready
well that's it well no baby no yeah here
we go
I can't stop thinking about that you've
done it every mouthful and
Cheers my request that you don't let off
the hook thank you first the warm-up
then I joined the squad for full-on